good morning Millennials welcome back to
the chosen happy Tuesday hope
everybody's having a great day speaking
of greatness it's Jack y by thank you f
la la la la la la
la la
F I know I sound like a broken record
and I know everyone's sick of me in my
[__] but I'm about to gouge my own
[__] eye out at this point my eye
twitch is worse than it's been like
today's the worst day it's ever been and
it's really starting to piss me the [__]
off now I'm getting angry you know I'm
thinking you know I could live without
this eye give it a shot an eye for an
eye a whole ass
month I'm being punished what did I
do did you look into it I did I did all
the things I've been taking magnesium I
drank tonic water I'm trying to like cut
back on blue light like I don't know
what the [__] it is I just feel like you
shouldn't give it the attention that it
wants and maybe it'll go away like kind
of starve it of
attention Okay like no because that's
not a thing and it's bothering me like
if you ignore
it it might just go away and it
definitely gets worse when we're
podcasting because the bright lights
like cannot be good for it that I do
feel when I have a migraine It's just
sometimes I honestly I'm team like you
never let me turn my lights off but I
say turn your lights off turn them off
um I'm about to get an eye patch like I
think I I need to wear eye patch for a
few days well you should have done that
a month ago or M by the way I think I
said that I wanted to wear an eye patch
and you were like telling me not to
because like you you said I was just
doing it so I can make it my personality
oh well you would be doing it to make it
your personality but how are you going
to wear an eye patch and it not beat
your personality I need to go pick one
up
this you should 100% the show could use
an ey patch I'm always Pro patch when
someone yeah when someone's having like
an eye issue like throw a patch on it
that's it's hysterical it's hysterical
and I also think ey patches like really
work yeah no they do it's a reason why
like it's one of those like medical
remedies that's been around since the
dawn of man and it's still around like
it's it's like very simple physics let
to see if I can order one on gopu I feel
like they would have one your eye needs
a break right give it a break how about
a
patch R mate but you have to say R matey
I mean the Tik toks
the reals from the show I'm getting an
eye patch you're so behind on the patch
you know what Julia yeah I was thinking
the same you can instag one I think
there's a Dwayne Reed on the corner
maybe we should just go grab one for
immediate relief let's have an eye patch
by the end of the show an eye patch by
the end of the show that's the goal okay
by the way now my eye even feels better
just knowing there's a solution on the
horizon not me podcasting with a pirate
do we need any snacks while we're out at
the pharmacy get Pirates Booty no we're
good that's it thank you but I thought
you going to take it all the
way what your pirate Persona Pirates
wouldn't eat Pirates Booty pirates eat
like their own [__] like they have
nothing they have no resources they
don't eat their own [__] they I mean
human beings no but they like they
they're aren't Pirates like thieves yeah
so they pillage the goods right and when
they fall on tough times they eat their
own poop no that's not a thing just like
Theo did when he was really young we
discovered he was malnourished cuz he
was eating his own
poop do eating
do T that's so Theo so I am at this
place in my healing where I cannot stop
making video montages I just saw I was
watching one right before we started
like I try and find the saddest song and
like I just am so like I have so much
content of Theo like even though he was
only with us for six years like six
years is a long time in in life and he
was such a beautiful I know everyone's
like my dog is beautiful yeah sure my
dog was was exceptional looking maybe
one of the most beautiful dogs like to
ever grace the planet the way people
would stare when he walked down the
street like I knew he was special
looking and I know everyone says that
but like really we all know Theo was
like extraordinary looking right yeah
but I like I feel the exact same way
about Shan like no of course everyone
does and I really wonder if every dog
parent thinks that their dog is the most
beautiful thing to Grace the world yes
but the difference between me and them
is like think that of course cuz like
I'm his mom but also because it's true
like right but would all dog parents say
the same yes because like I know that
when I would walk Theo down the street
every single person would turn their
head I walk past some dogs on the street
I don't give them a second look like
right no say but like I I everything
you're saying I feel the same no and by
the way I Bruno is also very very
beautiful but and he's definitely more
beautiful than most dogs for sure but
he's not more beautiful than Theo well I
I I don't want to get into this because
it's just
well let me just get back to my point of
why I brought it up just I didn't mean
to you know pit dogs against dogs but
but he's so beautiful I like spent so
much of my life just filming him because
I was aware of his Beauty and in awe of
it so I have found you know stitching
those videos together and making little
montages for my Tik Tok and my Instagram
I have found it to be really healing
honestly like I go and find the saddest
song Yesterday I made one to Rainbow by
Casey MUSC in that song that one
actually made me a little too sad cuz
when we were in the waiting room like I
was singing to Theo and I started
singing Rainbow
from not in the waiting room sorry in
the actual like euthanization room I
started singing Rainbow because I was
like what's the saddest song I can think
of right now and that was it and the
words were like very appropriate um so
that one like I kind of took the
montaging like I montaged too close to
the Sun understood well I feel like it
is kind of meant to be an emotional self
harm where you're just trying to like
excavate and like poke at the wound to
make it hurt it's emotional self harm
yes but I also think that is Expediting
the grieving process like the more tears
you cry the sooner the faster like I
feel like you you have to cry a certain
amount of Tears like that whatever the
elment is so if you get it all out
sooner you can move on faster I mean I I
I don't know if that's true but I hope
that it is yesterday I actually had a
fine day I only cried once when the tub
is really triggering for me but like I'm
not giving up my tub when I got out of
the tub I started crying but then I was
fine Ben had a bad day yesterday like he
was really in it he like kind of snapped
at me because I like asked him to go get
me frozen yogurt
and that's just like that's our thing
like I ask for stuff and he brings it
like it's we've never had an issue with
like this whole setup like it's perfect
and he just kind of snapped at me and I
didn't get mad because like I knew
exactly like he was just taking his
anger out on me and I do that too so I
wasn't even mad but I knew something was
seriously wrong when he kind of you
know deined revolted against the order
of our home right but it's like Ben's
not feeling like himself therefore he
cannot perform typical Ben duties I know
but like I'm performing my typical
duties like literally the other day I
noticed Ben was out of body wash or like
about to be so I got new body wash and I
got like a new one I wanted to see if
you would like it I got Nivea you know
something different and he didn't say
anything and I was like by the way do
you like your new body wash he's like
yeah why I'm like did you want to say
thank you or like did you wonder how
this no body wash just falls from the
sky you didn't know yeah I'm like did
you wonder how this big full container
of body wash got into your shower
let alone our home but I put it in the
shower it fell down from the sky because
God knew he needed more body wash so I
haven't been been more derc in my duties
so go get me ice cream right go get me
ice
cream but sometimes it's not tip for Tat
sometimes one is down and the other
leans supports Ben was down yesterday so
like I was kind of like the strong one
which I haven't been so he deserves it
that's really beautiful turny he needs
time then we watch Gossip Girl and we
got us out of our Funk loving watching
Gossip Girl it's been very healing as
well
oh that's all I hope for you tury l is
healing one day at a time one day at a
time that's what they say and it really
is true you take it day by day you
really do mhm and now I think I'm at the
point where I'm like really itching for
another dog like I feel like something's
missing and of course that thing is Theo
but knowing that I could partially fill
that
hole I'm like why am I why aren't I
doing that you will like you're
literally going away next week like give
yourself a second me and Ben were also
thinking about names how fun how fun I
would love to suggestions I gave you two
amazing suggestions what was it
Sheffield Sheffield yeah well Jackie
gave me the idea to because the thing
about Theo and I loved Theo's name but
it's actually a name like I might
consider one day for a child and the
fact that I took it for a dog and took
it out of the running it was too it was
too real so Jackie was like why don't
you choose a name that you would never
use like maybe a name from a TV show so
that got me thinking about shows that me
and Ben have been obsessed with you
suggested Sheffield from the NY which I
love and I also sest suggested Harvey
from Suits oh well you I suggested
Harvey but you gave me the platform to
suggest Harvey really yeah [__] I wish
our facetimes were recorded because like
how this show is because I have no
recourse I know but um I also really
want to figure out a way to name him
after LS lit but what am I going to name
my dog Lewis you can't even spell LS or
pronounce it most of the time it's so
true and then you'll be like Lou even
though I do like the name you would have
to spell it l e w so there's no
confusion confusion but that's no
offense to anyone listening with that
name like that's an ugly name stop not
if it was for your boy yeah so any name
suggestions maybe DOA if we get a girl
you know if you get a girl that's cute
but I do want a boy but I I'm I'll take
what I can get so I'm trying to think
from your other I've got it I've got it
are you ready Sheldon sh Shelly
Shelly
Den Shelly Shelly Sheldon well that
reminds me yesterday was probably one of
the craziest days of my life because of
Jackie so every year on patreon we do
this one episode and it's called the
vast five where we basically do a recap
of the Year where we do our top
five3 Fast Five of our favorite albums
songs TV shows that we watched uh books
that we read and it's just kind of a
nice way to end the year recap think
about all the things we went through
this year all the things watch this year
all the things we consume this year so
we recorded it yesterday it was great
and Jackie gets up from her chair we're
sitting just like this Jackie gets up
from her chair and she's like oh my
God and my first thought was oh she was
pumping during the episode so she
probably got up and like forgot her
nipple things were on and like spilled
the milk everywhere which is like liquid
gold I'm like oh [__] that sucks I
really felt for you in that moment but
what came out of your mouth next was so
much [__] worse than that yeah oh my
God I wasn't
recording my eye was twitching I was
like you weren't
recording now in that moment I had two
options I could have been like so mad
and I think I would have have had every
right to be but a part of being a
podcaster is this happens like whether
you like it or not whether you have the
best technology whether you have a
thousand people in the room this just
happens yeah so I don't know when the
last time it happened to me was but I
know it'll happen to me in the future
maybe you know tomorrow maybe in five
years I know my time is coming and I
want Grace
and I want someone to you know not hate
me even though they have every right to
you shall have Grace I actually feel
like I remember we've never had we've
never done a whole episode and not had
it we've sometimes done like half an
episode in someone's garage Banquets
when we used to do like our old remote
setup yes so we'd have to start like 30
minutes in yeah that's like the last
time that that happened I also remember
when we first got our that like it's
called a zoom box remember when we used
to do patreon episodes with those mics
like half the time wasn't record it was
like not there so it's been a very long
time since we've had that feeling I was
literally doing so much yesterday and
today like I'm just booked every minute
and I'm like always just doing like two
things at once so I was pumping and
podcasting and something slipped through
the cracks and like I just I didn't if
you were mad that we had to do it again
like I'm doubly mad like I had this hour
carved out yeah we have to do it
again and it was just we did do it again
it wasn't so bad the thing is is
sometimes we do an episode that like
really we got magic in a bottle like we
just randomly went on a tangent ended up
with like the funniest little bit and I
actually didn't love my performance in
that first episode my eye was twitching
and I was feeling really sad about Theo
so I was just kind of like letting the
podcast happen around me and I wasn't
that upset about the content that we
lost I was just obviously upset about
the energy I exerted for that and then
having to do it again so of all the
podcast to have to like have lost yeah
and as we were saying on the episode
like for that episode in particular we
make an outline where we like do and we
never have an outline for a show we
never have a script but like we just had
to like go through the outline again so
it was the best episode to have to lose
but oh my God and then we inadvertently
wound up podcasting for three and a half
hours yesterday because we did three
hour plus episodes yeah but the thing
is it happens it does at least just know
it will happen to me I I would rather
have been you in this situation not the
one who's at fault just the victim yeah
that's be a
victim searching for victimhood as was
the victim right like you just everyone
feeling sorry for you mad at me well we
ended up recording an even better
episode so everything happens the way
that it was meant to happen and that
episode is now available on the patreon
if you're looking for our year at a
glance check that out that'll be great
today's Tuesday so we've just got good
stories correct yeah yeah three strong
two weak oh you know we talked about
this on the scrapped patreon but we
haven't talked about it on the regular
toast and I actually do want to get your
take on it because there has been some
drama in the UK London British drama
between Molly May and Tommy Fury I had
seen it on Tik Tok unfolding essentially
like a couple weeks ago this video got
posted and it went super viral um Tommy
was out of town so like Molly's at home
with the baby and Tommy was at a club
and somebody like did a video just
panning of the booth and all the people
in the booth at this club and weirdly
Chris Brown was there and the next to
him was Tommy Fury and in the video he
appears to just being like playful with
a young gal now he wasn't kissing
nothing outright wrong but it was like
flirty playful he gave her like a little
push like and then the video moved away
from them and obviously the internet
went into a tail spin because so many
people like you like stand these two
they like think they're the best most in
loveed couple I don't know that much
about them I really only know what I
know through you yeah but give me your
take I need to find the video because I
didn't really I'll send it to you right
now I didn't really know about this
until CLA told me someone messaged me
like did you see the Molly Tommy drama
and because I hadn't seen anything I
just assumed like because they weren't
together for a long period of time
people assume there was drama so Claudia
told me there's this um thing of his you
know being playful I just texted it to
you but based on everything that like I
think that I know about them like I have
a lot of faith in the Bedrock of their
relationship and he really I mean I
would be shocked and anyone are we like
on a FaceTime oh oh my God I'm not okay
what because on my phone it says I can
join this face time so I literally we're
on FaceTime so I said are we on a
FaceTime we
are wait watch a video and then as you
watch video I have to correct one thing
I said yesterday when we were recapping
oh you see it no this is nothing and if
I was Tommy like that girl is
annoying oh okay Jackie says it's
nothing it's nothing I mean the thing is
like why is he out at a club when he's
like barely at home cuz he's always
training so it's like if you're not
training like go home now he also is a
brand ambassador for a lot of things so
maybe these are part of his duties of G
to events and stuff but that girl like
taking his face and pushing him like
maybe I I'm just someone who hates
having my face touched but like the
restraint this man is showing like get
the [__] out of my face ho okay that's a
Vibe I see Jackie says this girl is
being like thirsty and annoying and he's
G he gave her
nothing okay that's that on that but I'm
also you know a Molly Tommy apologist I
go hard for my favorite ships and I can
often be wrong and in denial do you want
to hear the craziest thing just look at
me don't look at anything else okay mhm
if you had to guess how long we've been
podcasting this morning how long would
you say we've been talking oh I guess I
did just look at the clock but oh I
would have said 10 minutes we're already
at 17 minutes like that really flew by
time is a social construct yeah so I
think guess we did have the whole eye
patch thing I think Molly and Tommy are
okay I think it's like an embarrassing
look for Molly and then you were saying
like people are talking about how like
Molly's life is like totally changed
since she had the baby and Tommy's
really
hasn't I think they're okay like the way
that Tommy talks about her the things
that he has said I I think he's a
faithful man I really do and I I would
be shocked if there's any fire near this
smoke
okay now I really quickly wanted to
correct myself something I said
yesterday when I was going off about my
football rant I I mixed up two things
when we were talking about Patrick
Mahomes he so I was telling the story
about how he was being like a big cry B
baby and going up to the quarterback
afterwards and like you know crying
about the call and the flag and I said
Travis did that I meant Patrick I just
got the names confused but it was
Patrick I just want to correct that and
the L played the Ravens not the lack
even though they're the same thing to me
the eye patch has arrived our
Mayer oh we got two different options oh
okay we have the traditional you know
Black on on a string but then they make
new breathable no ones with no string no
black on a string black on a string like
it's giving SpongeBob it's like the
mouse trap like you can't build a better
mouse trap you cannot build a better eye
patch okay I'm taking my headphones off
one second okay tury is putting on her
eye patch R
matey she's having a difficult time but
I think it's going to oh there it
goes
okay gorgeousness I mean like make sure
you're comfortable because you're
wearing I'm not right you don't look
comfortable I think it's kind of upside
down okay I was thinking it's upside
down too hold on yeah the the
string I wish she could hear me because
the double string double
string okay the double string you just
put the same way I did I think so but is
there two strings no there's just one
I'm okay I just now I'm learning I don't
think my right eye has very good
eyesight give it a second to adjust it's
never been on its own before
also am I supposed to keep my eye closed
in this thing I think it's dealer's
Choice whatever is more comfortable for
your eye as it takes its little
Hiatus okay it just it doesn't look
right or comfortable or sustainable and
we need it to sustain cuz we've got a
lot to do today we haven't even cracked
the Fast Five story so she's yeah there
are double string it is double string
there's not double
strings
okay that looks better how does that
look that looks much better okay yeah
cuz the string is like more parallel not
I have a question for you at such an
angle yes are you ready kids I I turty I
can't hear you I I turty oh
oh oh without further
adoo it is time for the fast five
stories that you need to know oh God I
got one eye okay ready mhm the fast five
stories that you need to know are
brought to you by State Farm the State
Farm personal price plan helps you
create an affordable price just for you
the plan's all about being personal to
you and your needs so that means you get
the coverage you want a policy that
helps cover what's important to you and
an affordable price just for you because
after all life is just better when you
can personalize your experiences think
about it like this from your go-to
coffee order to your favorite pair of
sweatpants we know that you love to
personalize your entire day just like we
do because what's more personal than
podcasting I mean what's more personal
than comedy what's more personal than
poetry than food so many things in life
are personal and State Farm understands
that CU State Farm has big toasty energy
BTE and insurance is even more personal
take Jackie and I for example we are so
similar we finished each other's SE
sentences and sandwiches and even we
have such
distinct insurance needs like Jack is a
homeowner I'm not Jackie is dependent
Theo's
dead clearly personalization just makes
everything that much better State Farm
believes that insurance should work the
same way your plan your coverage your
selections can all be personalized to
you like a good neighbor State Farm is
there prices vary by state options
selected by customer availability and
eligibility may vary let me try that one
more time because I know Jake from State
far was like 30ty that was not good
enough like a good
neor honestly my whole equilibrium is
off with this thing like a good neighbor
stay Farm is there that was good ja you
want to give it a go like a good
neighbor stay Farm is
there gorgeous today's episode is also
brought to you by
ag1 if you want to give ag1 a try
because you're tired of taking
supplements every day and you just want
a single solution that supports your
entire body by filling in nutrient gaps
then check out ag1 you need energy you
want to simplify your morning routine
with easy habits or you want to support
your gut health while also supporting
your immune and brain health check out
ag1 Ben Sofer favorite sponsor on the
planet our whole family is hooked on ag1
we're going on a family trip and they're
literally having ag1 shipped by the case
load because we're obsessed yeah it's
just a great way to start your day I
like to take it for digestion I think
it's just a great thing to do in the
morning to get your you know stomach
your bowels on point there's a million
different reasons that you might want to
do it whether it's gut health you have
nutrient gaps in your diet ag1 will help
you feel more energized strong and
nourished it delivers your daily dose of
vitamins minerals pre and probiotics but
it's also a powerful healthy habit
that's powerfully simple just one scoop
mix it in water once a day every day
like I wake up to the sound of the ag1
being shaken Ben has like this special
cup he does it in it's going to simplify
and enhance your daily supplement
routine and ag1 is a supplement that we
trust to provide our body the needs what
it needs daily and that's why we're
excited to welcome them as a new partner
here's your chance to start every day
this season with a gift to yourself try
aging1 and get a free one-year supply of
vitamin D3 K2 and five free ag1 travel
packs with your first purchase
exclusively at drink a1.com toast that's
drink a1.com toast check it out today's
episode is also brought to you by
storyworth if you're spending time with
loved ones for the holidays chances are
you're going to hear a lot of stories
but ones you love to hear and the ones
you've heard too many times but if you
ever wanted to help your loved ones
document those Timeless stories it can
be challenging to write an entire Book
of Life memories but story worth makes
it fun and easy this is how anyone can
write a book about their life every week
story worth will email your loved one a
single life related question that you
pick from their collection like what's
the bravest thing you've ever done
where's the farthest you've ever
traveled what's the farthest you've ever
traveled
Jackie physically or mentally God
physically Israel probably Israel for me
too um and then all that person has to
do is reply with a story after a year
story worth Will compile all of your
loved ones stories memories photos into
an Exquisite hard cover book creating a
valued keepsake millions of stories have
already been told with story worth
because they make the process so simple
get started with your loved ones for the
holiday before you know it you'll both
be cherishing those Timeless stories for
generations to come this is the most
creative gift hands down so sweet so
thoughtful So Different yeah and I love
a digital gift because you can give it
up until any point and it turns into a
physical gift which is best of both
worlds I actually just did an ad for
story worth yesterday and I can wax
poetic about how it's such a wonderful
gift I gave it to Dana last year because
she's the master Storyteller that's cute
and I worry that she's going to run out
of storage in her brain like jot these
stories down Dana let them go release
them into the world and put it in a book
put it in the book help your family
share their story this holiday season
with storyworth go to storyworth.com
toast toay and save $10 on your first
purchase that's storyworth s t o r y w r
t.com toast to save $10 on your first
purchase storyworth.com toast thank you
lur de get wels our first story Zach
Efron finally gets a star in the
Hollywood Walk of Fame I feel like we
manifested this we're always talking
about his accolades
his Cannon his body of work his catalog
so he got his star he made a really
sweet speech thinking everyone who
helped him along the way including Kenny
Ortega High School Musical go wild cats
Matthew Perry 17 again it was the
perfect culmination of not only Zach
Efron's career but like of pop culture
like I always find it so interesting who
people bring to speak on their behalf to
the Hollywood Walk of Fame thing like
usually people bring other celebrities
so him having Miles Teller Jeremy Allen
White like okay he just wanted to
collect like the hottest men of
Hollywood and have them there love that
for him what is he oh Miles Teller he
did that awkward moment with oh I was
wondering how they knew each other that
did I forgot about that I forgot about
that too I'm glad that they remained
friends because they played such good
friends in the movie I wonder if they're
still close with Michael B Jordan too oh
I wonder that um I couldn't figure out
how Miles Taylor knew him so thank you
and then Jeremy Ellen White and him are
in a movie that's coming out soon about
wrestlers oh I didn't know that either I
I was like I wonder how this Band of
Brothers got together but I just figured
when you all live in Hollywood and
you're all so hot you just find your way
to one another yeah you would think but
I feel like it doesn't happen as often
as it should well this is a moment where
just like things are right in the world
and I appreciate that I loved his speech
I loved loved loved that he brought
Kenny Ortega because I feel like you
know out of all the High School Musical
people he acknowledges the franchise the
least some of them acknowledge it too
much yeah and sometimes you wonder like
does he hate it but like him putting
respect on Kenny's name on the franchise
for obviously catapulting him to fame I
just I thought this was so beautiful and
then him mentioning Matthew Perry was so
sweet like so like unnecessary honestly
I I don't think anybody would have said
anything if he didn't but it was really
sweet yeah no he really hit every point
I didn't see the whole speech so like I
do need to know if he mentioned like
greatest showman in Hairspray but I
didn't see any headlines about it but he
also said he sings High School Musical
songs in the shower and he said quote go
wild cats now let me ask you a question
in your opinion what is Zack Efron's
greatest Film SL cinematic achievement
in my opin objectively or subjectively
in your
opinion as Zach Efron or the movie that
he's in like
role like Z Efron okay so not Philip
carile and greatest showman honestly
even though greatest showman was the
best
one I have to look at the catalog T I
need to do my research I need to educate
myself quickly cuz I think I would say
hairspray I'm tempted to but I want to
just make sure he should have had Nikki
blansky there he should have had Nikki
blansky there the only way it would have
been better High School Musical oh yeah
yeah yeah sorry like three Troy Bolton
doing the Most High School
Musical okay she said what she said I I
think I'm GNA stick with hairspray but I
also just one I feel like there's one or
two other movies that I'm forgetting
musicals no just good neighbors he was
very popular for I saw that I I blew
right past it I feel like this eye patch
is impacting my ability to speak I don't
notice a difference okay I feel like I'm
literally
stuttering I feel like he was in
something really good hold on he was in
Baywatch not really good that was
probably a low point for him
dead maybe not perhaps but he has a very
impressive oh yeah like Mike and Dave
need wedding D said I'm just breezing
past all these things he was in you know
the lucky one I think that's Nicholas
Sparks uh he's in a lot of things but
his best work
remains high school music High School
Musical and then I love him and then
hairspray and then greatest showman now
I hate to be one of these people cuz
it's just rude but I am
curious do you know what I'm going to
say why does he look so different like I
hate when people like who is that
especially with like women but like he
does look so different I feel like every
once in a while there's like a picture
of him that's like oh my God that's Z
Evon but at his no Jackie he does look
incredibly different his Walk of Fame
yeah he looks a little different but not
as like
for lack of a better word crazy as some
of those
pictures yeah yeah but but like what
happened he had some work on okay he had
some work right crazy yeah okay okay
listen we've all been there but to me
he's like still the most like the most
eligible handsome man on the
planet oh I love him I love him too but
he's not no I love him and he just like
keeps beefing
up yeah I need him to like get get his
ass back to the theater like I need him
to do more musicals I know but he's
doing like his big hunky rolles right
now and he also did like uh that Netflix
show where he almost died right he's
really into that Wilderness stuff like
be grills
yeah go back to dancing put your tap
shoes on Zach I just I I just love that
he still has love for it let's like even
though he's a man of the Wilderness now
he will always look back fondly on his
days of T dancing and your Hollywood
Walk of Fame like really is supposed to
be like a culmination of your entire
career so I do feel like you really
nailed it with like having Kenny Ortega
there which is a nod to his dancing
shoes having Miles Teller there which is
like a not to those movies he made a
bunch of movies that were all really
similar like romcom Vibes yeah and um
Jeremy Allen White to the future you
know yeah past present and
future yeah he has a brother that looks
familiar is he an actor no but he's
always like going viral for having a
brother that's funny wait no he has an
IMDb just wait that doesn't mean he's
famous just oh he's a producer and
executive okay so he's not in front of
the oh he worked on Zach's show down Toe
with Zack Efron it's so cute siblings
who work together maybe we'll be them
for Halloween okay shout out Zack I love
Zack Efron like I just I just love him
no I love him that's what I'm saying you
know what I would love what Memoirs of
an
Ephron I feel like he has a lot to say
mhm and I feel like he's experienced
like real Peaks and valleys in his
career like from the from after
uh High School Musical to you know all
the movies we've just remarked on I feel
like there was highs and lows and a lot
of times where he's had to reinvent
himself where he probably also felt very
like pigeon hold and typ cast as like
this teeny bopper and then he tries to
be the romcom guy and he did that
successfully and now he wants to be like
the leading man buff Indie guy doing
that successfully yeah no that's such a
good point I just feel like he probably
and he's also just been aist for a
really long time and that always makes a
good Memoir a memoir I did finish Keenan
Thompson's Memoir last night um I can't
lie I did skim through like a bunch of
it it it when he got to his SNL stuff it
was really really interesting also just
like little tidbits about SNL like how
much you make everyone signs a
seven-year contract and they can let you
go at any time but if you if they keep
you on like every year you get like a
little incremental raise and then after
your seventh year I think is when you
can like make a lot of money but like a
lot of the castmates have like they
subsidize
their yeah they do they no I mean not
most of them aren't movie Material so
they do like standup and like you know
comedy and different they write
different things anything that doesn't
conflict with SNL but a lot of like the
early years where you're not as famous
you're not making a lot of money and you
can't really do huge projects like
movies yeah but I feel like when an SNL
person is making a movie it's like they
get all SNL people like a lot of the SNL
cast members they all kind of like ride
together and they're they're supporting
actors in a lot of different movies like
I feel like there are roles for you and
opportunities like just abound when you
sign on to SNL so my takeaway from
Keenan's book is I don't know if I would
recommend it he is a PE job he's so and
I think that makes that's what makes his
book like not super super interesting
he's just like a really normal really
nice guy now he's at the stage of his
life where he's really just a family man
he's trying to get healthy you know it's
not like titillating you know no one's
doing cocaine or you know or he's just
not telling you about it no he says like
he he says when he spoked to pot he's
just like I'm not like that like at SNL
I mean oh not him it doesn't seem like
he's you know no he's really sweet he
grew up like very normal too you know um
so there wasn't like crazy like I always
compareed to like Jessica Simpson like
the way she grew up was so nuts you know
there wasn't any of that he just like
loved his family his family loved him
really supportive mom dad and brother
really supportive community in Atlanta
so it was like nice but boring got it
that's good boring is good yeah boring
is good that's like I think he he
probably has like the most healthy work
life balance of anyone in Hollywood you
hope so yeah that's what his Uber driver
say so are you ready for our next story
his book did corroborate what a lot of
my Uber drivers have said I would hope
so I I would hope that his book would
make him look like a good guy yeah you
know yeah are you ready for our next
story
mhm bner pump world's trailer just
dropped did you watch it yes I did I
mean everyone's talking about that one
thing Tom Schwarz Sheena oh no la la I
don't know someone who gets broken up
with and becomes god well I didn't see
anyone talking about that I watched the
trailer like right before we recorded
and that line just stuck with me it's
true okay okay so everyone is saying
like it's giving jealous cuz you know
Randall cheated on you and you didn't
become God and you I didn't even think
that what I was thinking it's like well
L you're one of the people who like made
her God like all of the cast members
like Ariana literally God is Queen and
now you're mad that everyone's treating
her like God when like you were treating
her like God for sure but I like I kind
of agree with what she's saying like it
it is insane what happened to Ariana
when Ariana got cheated on which is
horrible but like so many people get
cheated on and don't make millions of
dollars yeah no when she said that I was
like oh wow someone saying it and it's
and it's who's like obsessed with her
she must be really like on one but she's
like hyping her up so how do we she's
been hyping her up right like and
everybody was doing that and now I guess
they're mad about it I didn't even think
about the Lala being cheated on thing um
maybe I'm just like naive and I trust
people's intentions but I don't think
that's what you meant but from an
outsider's perspective I can understand
how haters would be like you're just
jealous jealous right I don't think
she's jealous I mean I might be yeah but
I think I feel like lala got her pound
of Flesh from Scandal Lala capitalized
probably the most out of anyone with the
podcast send it to Daryl yeah because
Ariana like wasn't speaking out and she
was letting people like and everyone
like gave it their best effort to like
monetize and capitalize on Scandal and I
think that at the end of the day if you
look at the balance sheet Lala did the
best after Ariana outside outside of the
principal characters right yeah so
Sheena did good too so I feel like
things have to probably have hit a fever
pitch for like lala to be complaining
about it mhm that was tea to me also
then the fact that Schwarz Apparently
one time made out with Sheena in Vegas
when he was dating Katie it's seems like
but this could also just be the what the
trailer is making it seem like it seems
like that might cause an issue between
Brock and Sheena because I guess that'd
be kind of weird if you've made out with
someone in your friend group and you
never told your
husband
yeah I don't know with this particular
like in for normal people yes with this
particular group I don't know I don't
know if that's the reason why they are
fighting on the side sidewalk also
there's a woman who is in a love
triangle with Katie and Schwarz She's
kissing both of them oh I missed that
right that's what I thought I saw oh
that's interesting and what about uh
Timothy shalamay who's that Katie no
Timothy shalam who's that
sandal Timothy shalam from last
season oh Satchel satchel
I forgot his name How Could You Forget
Satchel I just know that he looked like
Timothy xalam Satchel is nowhere to be
found unfortunately right and that's why
the season doesn't have what it takes
and that's why the season will not be
winning an Emmy the thing is the season
actually looks pretty good considering
how do we have anything interesting to
talk about after Scandal there looks to
be like some dumb typical stuff of like
why are Ariana and Tom living together
why is Tom filming oh we're drawing a
Line in the Sand BL so Marana was on
watch Happens Live explaining why they
live together they own the house they
both paid for it she wants to sell it he
refuses so she is now in the legal
process of trying to force him to buy
her out because he's forcing her to stay
there like you bought a house and you're
not going to live there like that's your
life savings no I but she did say for
the last couple of months while being on
Dancing With the Stars because you film
somewhere else she's been living in like
an Airbnb I like agree on principal yeah
that's your money's in the house but
like how are you living in the same like
even if you have to go stay with a
friend and concede the house just so you
can like start your life with I couldn't
look at that person every day for sure I
also have to imagine like a lawyer would
advise you not to leave the
house
yeah and then also she said something
about you took my house and and I'm I'm
going to have my house and my and my
children did they make embryos they had
started they were talking about it they
did something she froze her eggs but did
they make embryos I don't know cuz far
as I knew they did not make it to the
embryo stage but if she's saying that
and they have embryos together that's
crazy and then that's you know Sophia
varara that's like a long legal road
yeah and it's like does she have eggs
that aren't part of those embryos oh my
God that would suck
yeah yeah I don't know it the thing is I
want to this is just not even based on
the trailer just based on what we know I
do think this
season I would say like the last season
while obviously that's when Scandal
happened I felt like they dropped the
ball in a lot of places in terms of like
footage and just filming and so I think
there's actually a lot more potential
for this season yeah the aftermath
like what I think that based on the
trailer like we have a season a good one
for sure yeah for sure so that's
exciting and it it comes out the end of
January so like a a little over a month
away not Terri not terrible no cuz they
released the Bridgerton trailer uh for
May well that's a great segue to our
next story Bridgerton season 3 sets a
two-part Premiere in Spring of
2024 but this is what we get for the
strike spring don't be giving me seven
monthly time for a trailer nobody needs
that for a TV show I agree Bridgerton is
returning to Netflix in 2024 with the
third season of the period drama
Waltzing on to streaming in two parts
the first four episodes will premere on
May 16th and the next four will be
available to stream on June 13th don't
even I'm not getting started on not
bingeable content after they conditioned
us to be binge watching content no and
it's like June 2024 like I don't know
who I'll be then I don't know where I'll
be like this is insane
yeah and I'm not saying like they're not
moving quick enough like I understand
the strike really impeded their keep it
under wraps then no it's insane and the
trailer was like such [__] they used
like a bunch of social media Tik toks
talking about Bridgerton with like three
scenes from the actual season cuz they
don't even know haven't filmed yet why
are they doing this I don't know there
has to be a reason it was like a fake
trailer what are they worried about that
we're going to forget about
Bridgerton I
guess that's weird there's something
something is a
foot you think it's my eye patch no I
think your ey patch is amazing is it
helping no not at all but I I like I am
I think it gives the show another layer
and dimension that we need and think
about our clips from today people are
going to be like why is turty wearing an
I patch like the engagement will be off
the charts agreed we have to only clip
from I patch on off the
charts oh off the
charts very good ja very good thank you
are you ready for our next story it's
our fourth
story it's our fourth story it's our
fourth story
no I'm not ready I didn't think you were
ready but I thought that maybe you could
get ready ready you should get ready
ready today's fourth and fifth stories
are brought to you by hatch oh I just
love the hatch even though today I had
such a problem with my hatch because Ben
made me set it so early so I woke up so
you know naturally and gorgeously and
then what we woke up early for actually
got canceled so I was I've been up for
hours maybe that's why I have an eye
twitch today's Fast Five is brought you
by hatch which is so appropriate because
this morning I woke up beautifully
albeit earlier than I needed to but I'm
fine waking up to the sunrise on my
Hatcher store instead of my iPhone alarm
has literally changed my life it's added
to the list of things Jackie told me
about I was like yeah sure light could
never wake me up it wakes me up I pretty
much wake up before the actual music
every single day so here's what a hatch
does they will wake you up by light it's
basically like mimicking a sunrise and
so the light will very slowly and
gradually come on for 30 minutes before
you're actually set to wake up and then
if you're still not up by the 30 minute
alarm like they'll play this gorgeous
spa music it's so non-aggressive it's
such a humane way to wake up it has
really changed my life like I don't even
think I thank you properly or talk about
like give you enough credit for really
how much to hatch that's like one of my
favorite low-lift Wellness routine
things so there's no better soundtrack
for chili season than the hatch sounds
that's what we're currently waking up to
and winding down to on the hatra store
it's the perfect winter pairing so it's
a device that helps you build a con
consistent bed bedtime and morning
routine so you can prioritize rest and
sleep better great sleep can be learned
with hatch 83% of customers report
improved sleep and they have a 60-day 60
night money back guarantee so you can
try it for yourself risk-free right now
hatch is offering our listeners $20 off
their purchase of the hatch rest store
and free shipping at hatch. toast that's
hatch. toast to get that $20 off in free
shipping hatch. toast today's episode is
also brought to you by kiwi Co unwrap
inspiration with super fun science
technology and art projects for kids
with kiwi Co with nine different
subscription options for different ages
and subjects there's something for every
kid when you give kiwi Co it's so much
more than a box of toys it's the gift of
Discovery through Hands-On experiences
giving kids the tools to learn about
topics they love from dinosaurs to
rocket ships Kimo is the thing for kids
like if you have a kid in your life you
know how difficult it can be to keep
them occupied for more than five minutes
like you buy them a big fancy toy
they're over it in 5 seconds kiwi Co is
creative it's start to finish you're not
giving them a robot they're building a
robot it's fun it's educational it's
stimulating it keeps them busy all day
it's a box of awesome delivered monthly
the the day that your kiwi Co box
arrives it'll be your kids's favorite
day of the month they offer gifts with
Rich activities for kids of all ages and
interests and you can give your child
the tools to learn new skills build new
experiences and make connections to the
broader World kiwo projects are designed
by a team of Educators makers engineers
and Rocket scientists who brainstorm
hundreds of ideas to to create the most
exciting age appropriate and educational
projects these are real engineering
science and art projects with high
quality materials so discover Hands-On
fun with kiwi Co get your first month
free on any crate line at kiwico.com
toast that's your first month free at
kiwi.com
toast today's episode is also brought to
you by manscaped ladies today we are
brought to you by Santa's number one
helper manscaped this holiday season go
beyond the boring gifts and stuff those
stockings with something he actually
needs introducing the performance
package 5 .0 Ultra from manscaped the
Ultimate Grooming bundle designed to
treat his special snowflake so unwrap
the magic of the performance package 5.0
Ultra at its Helm the performance
package 5.0 has everything you need the
lawnmower 5.0 Ultra which is a two gen
two nextg blades blade heads for
precision grooming that's North Pole
approved it has skin safe technology and
waterproof capabilities also comes with
the um ear nose nose and hair trimmer it
comes with crop preserver anti-chafe
ball deodorant and the crop Soother
After Shave lotion so the gift of
manscape doesn't stop there the bundle
comes with two free gifts the boxers and
the shed 2.0 toiletry bag ladies we know
he's still wearing boxers from high
school so get him the best upgrade he
could ask for with the boxers 2.0
moisture wicking technology and
signature Jewel pouch to cradle his
presentence The Way They Were Meant to
so if your dad brother or boyfriend have
too much winter scruff look no further
than the manscaped beard Heder Pro kit
and handyman electric face shaver to
weather the storm get 20% off in free
shipping with code toast manscape.com
that's 20% off with free shipping at
manscape.com and use code toast his
balls will be singing Baby it's cold
outside our next Story the weather
outside is weather our next St is
Forgetting Sarah Marshall thank you a
picture is worth a thousand words Prince
William and Kate Middleton's kids look
so grown up in the 2023 royal family
Christmas card have you seen the pick I
have I've also seen Charlotte is getting
roasted what okay I I can't even give
that not for this picture not for this
picture um also a bit of what seems to
be a Photoshop fail in the picture did
you see this of Prince Lou's finger oh
I'm on my way I don't know what I can't
imagine they would really need to like
Photoshop these pictures but maybe had
like a snack in it that was the only way
they would like get him to stand still
he's a kid maybe that's true and we also
know that he's you know not he's a
little rascal he's a little rascal but
you have to see that kids look so grown
up it's shocking and the world is
shocked like that these pictures are
like going viral people can't believe
how big these kids are now so let me
take a look um but also let me tell you
why Charlotte's getting roasted cuz she
did like a holiday event with like an
official you know family thing she's
wearing the same coat she wore last
holiday but I feel like people like that
they do they do I'm kidding it shows
that they're relatable oh he's missing a
finger he's missing in a finger it seems
that's like really
obvious yeah I this is like a gorgeous
photo first of all these kids are just
but also Claudia if you zoom in like
really really close it it kind of looks
like his finger like taped down maybe
they had to tape him to the chair lol l
i don't know what's going on with the
finger but let's look past that for a
moment let's look past that cuz it is
distracting this is so modern you know
it's so edgy and very like editorial
it's very the opposite of everything we
get from them which is so traditional
and like stuffy but at the end of the
day just giving Calvin Klein it is
giving Calvin Klein but it's still just
like a family
portrait you know like it's really not
that crazy but it it does feel modern I
can't get over George and Charlotte like
he looks like King George like he's
kingly he looks really like his father
did at that age with the big hair like
it's amazing he has no hair left he
should get on that minoxidil stat um
he's a very very handsome young man he's
going to grow up to be you know really
really something beautiful yeah but he's
also just like becoming a young man and
know his pose he's like looks like a
person like yeah no he's a person now
and this Charlotte is such a beauty oh
like it's they're just a beautiful
family and I'm just surprised at like
the regularity of this Christmas card
like I feel like I got this one in the
mail from someone I know you know it's
so simple yeah but so elegant but so
elegant there's something so elegant
about it very refined I love I don't
know if I've ever seen Kate Middleton in
jeans she looks great she they all look
great and she's just got hair like she
is hair yeah her hair is gorgeous it's
shiny happy for them 10 out of 10
honestly oh and people are saying you
know that it's a nod to Princess Diana
she loved you know a button- down and
some
jeans like everybody's always saying
everything is about to literally like
button button- down and jeans is like
classic family picture look yeah it's
very American though don't you agree
yeah
I'm not complaining but plus like the
sneakers on the kids so cute this is
really 10 out of 10 T across the board I
have no notes I have no notes I agree
and I have notes for everything our
fifth and final story is a little crazy
inheritance news oh my God please be
about me no unfortunately it's
not the airto a maze is awarding I heard
this his 11 billion Fortune to his
51-year-old Gardener obsessed
80-year-old billionaire Nicholas Pooch
Sion of the iconic fashion Dynasty air
maze is allegedly orchestrating a
staggering succession Saga that involves
adopting his 51-year-old Gardener Pooch
who's unmarried and without children
plans to legally designate his former
Gardener and handyman from a modest
Moroccan family as his rightful Heir as
reported by a Swiss publication this
unorthodox move to pass on his immense
wealth and real estate properties to his
Gardener has sparked intense speculation
Pooch who's a fifth generation descent
fendant of tier's air maze who laid the
foundation for the luxury fashion house
in 1837 commands a considerable share in
the now $220 billion valued company
ranking among Switzerland's wealthiest
individuals allegedly he has initiated
legal proceedings supported by a
formidable legal team to formalize The
Gardener's adoption which forms a
crucial part of his revised estate plans
the how old is this man the the air The
Gardener's 51 the air is 80 okay the
gardener is reportedly married to a
woman from Spain with two children of
their own and stands to inherit a
significant portion of the fortune which
includes acquiring substantial
properties in maresh and Switzerland
valued at $5.9
million now what's the
speculation as to the motivation yeah
you said there was speculation oh well
so the if you look at pooch's history
provides a glimpse into the motivation
behind this a typical choice for his air
a bitter Rift emerged in 2014 when lvmh
acquired a substantial stake in air maze
sparking an acrimonious battle within
the family pooch's departure from the
company's board amid this turmoil
signaled irreparable Discord with his
kin he resigned because he felt for he
has for years beleaguered by members of
his family who have attacked him on
several fronts o oh vitim mentality his
unconventional plan faces formidable
challenges navigating complex legal
hurdles for an adult adoption an
exceedingly rare occurrence in Switzer
reports suggest requirements of for such
adoptions demand a prior relationship
during the adop's minor years I don't
think that happened here he had
previously committed his fortune to the
isocrates foundation established by him
to combat
misinformation attempts oh that's
vague now he's trying to retract this
pledge which might trigger a legal
battle akin to past family feuds this
guy kind of sounds like a mess yeah no
like he's just like always changing his
mind and the law is reason free from
Passion that which is why he started the
is Socrates Foundation yeah I don't know
that Foundation is giving me goosebumps
not in a good way like I just like it's
very general the oh the oh the the
foundation for misinformation combating
misinformation like in what
sense yeah it's weird I like I'd rather
The Gardener have it yeah of course but
also if you're so willy-nilly with your
fortune like break it up give some to
Socrates give some to me give some to
The Gardener like think give some to the
poor I don't think the gardener was
going to get everything but he was going
to get a lot and I think in order to
give it to him he has to adopt him which
is just kind of funny that is weird that
you can't just give your money to
whoever you want to maybe not when you
have like Family Ties who are ready to
snatch it back from you because they
already were pushing you out probably
cuz you're a weirdo yeah no he
definitely sounds like he's the problem
100%
yeah and is he dying or he's just making
plans for the future I think making
plans I didn't see any anything about
his State because then also that that
would be called into question like you
know if he wasn't doing well now he was
wanting to adopt a 50-year-old like
Grandpa's lost he have to make a video
Testament like I am of sound mind today
December 12th 2023 I have bequeathed I'm
no first I have I'm adopting my Gardener
right right I thought when you were
saying like that his motives are
suspicious like there's you know
theories and rumors that they're lovers
but then I'm like he works in fashion
why would anybody care if he's gay yeah
so maybe that's not it maybe they're not
lovers I don't think so but this is
interesting and you know
what it's beautiful I hope this Gardener
gets the money I love that for his
family and his children right and his
legacy
yeah where does the the guy live now the
Switzerland got it
okay huh
yeah
and he doesn't have any children no not
married
nothing well he will have a child when
he adopts his Gardener oh well now he
has a child right right right right
right yeah the adoption is just it's
just weird that that's the law but I
guess it kind of makes sense and it's
just like funny that it's called
adoption when it's a 50-year-old it's
actually so true can you adopt a
non-minor i well like one what's the
point you know because right they could
choose to some people do it for
sentimentality like I see that on Tik
Tok sometimes like someone's stepfather
when they're 23 like decides to just
adopt them cuz like legally it's like a
meaningful thing not like anything else
okay that's
sweet
but yeah it says here there Swiss law
that like unless you had a relationship
as a minor you might not actually even
be allowed to adopt a grown
man oh so the law is not reason free
from Passion
well it is reason free from pass
question cuz this would be his
passion
right I guess Aristotle is always right
when he spoke those Immortal words
yeah okay those were the Fast Five our
matey and I want to say I don't think
this eye patch is helping like in the
slightest I'm sorry to hear that you
want to know why like I needed something
oh you know
what I'm so dumb hold
on
I wonder what it
is cuz the thing I was feeling about the
eye patch was that it's like not forcing
my eye shut you have to put that in the
patch oh yeah there's like a hundred in
here okay okay my mascara is going to go
everywhere it's okay the show's
over it's a Band-Aid for your eye
eyebrows out Band-Aid for your eye yeah
this definitely this seals a
chut my God so much better I'm so
dumb okay better late than
never okay tury out aoy [__] thanks
for listening to today's episode oh my
god it feels so much better like you can
hear it in my
voice oh all right
tomorrow we keep your patch at the
studio yeah of course patch for the rest
of the
week I love it Mo not even modern
solutions right archaic solutions for
the win here for modern
aric solutions for the Modern Woman a
book by Jackie
ostree thank you guys so you're
listening to the toast the Millennium
Morning Show where we deliver the fast
five stories that you need to know every
Monday through Friday on YouTube so
you're watching us on YouTube please
feel free to subscribe and give this
video a thumbs up we're also available
as podcast anywhere podcast can be found
set Spotify iTunes Stitch public radio
iart radio cast box all the places
wherever you listen to podcast find us
the toast if I STV about our beautiful
stunning and wickedly talented we are
aoy matey have a great day and we'll see
you tomorrow all love you bye